This is an I-Heart podcast. Guaranteed Human. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. And on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world.
这是一个iHeart播客。百分之二。这是指在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客节目“百分之二”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中坚韧不拔的意志、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。
Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO. percent on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84 was big to me.
经历一些艰难困苦，你将以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听“百分之二”。也就是数字2%。可在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。在Look Back at it播客中。从1979年开始，那对我来说是一个重大时刻。84年对我来说意义重大。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a year, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. With our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. 84 was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people.
我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。我们的朋友、同行的喜剧演员以及最喜爱的作家。比如马克·拉蒙特·希尔谈论80年代。84年是一个疯狂的年份。那确实是个疯狂的年份。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeartRadio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kear Games. This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that it's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're having them with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that doesn't. not mean that you need to.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Look Back at it。嘿，大家好，最近怎么样？欢迎收听《以防万一》节目，我是你们最喜爱的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。这个空间专注于黑人男性的经历，进行在任何地方都极不安全的坦诚对话，但你是在与一位懂行的持证专业人士进行交流。有多少男人背负着一副盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。但这并不意味着只要你有这种能力，就一定非得这样做。
Listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins. But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg, a lesbian.
在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听《以防万一》。2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控生下了一对双胞胎。但这场怀孕似乎是一场骗局。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定的检测两次，对吗？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才揭露出一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格，一名女同性恋。
Michael Mancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hello everybody and welcome back to the psychology of your 20s, the podcast where we talk through some of the big life changes and transitions of our 20s and what they mean.
迈克尔·曼奇尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。大家好，欢迎回到《你二十岁的心理学》，这是一个探讨我们二十岁时面临的重大生活变化与转变及其含义的播客。
for our psychology. Hello everybody. Welcome back to the show. Welcome back to the podcast, new listeners, old listeners. Whatever you are in the world, it is so great to have you here back for another episode of the show as we of course break down the psychology of our 20s. Before we get into it today, I want to let you guys know that my latest line of notebooks in collaboration with the illustrator Rosie Pink have launched and a live.
关于我们的心理学。大家好。欢迎回到节目。欢迎新老听众再次收听本播客。无论你身在世界的哪个角落，很高兴你能回来收听节目的又一期，当然，我们将在这里剖析我们二十岁的心理学。在今天的正题开始之前，我想告诉大家，我与插画师罗莎·平克合作推出的最新笔记本系列已经上市并已。
live now and ready for you guys to get your hands on. A lot of love and care went into designing and producing these beautiful companions to the podcast. If you're somebody who likes journaling, who likes to take notes while listening, who likes, I don't know, just a gratitude journal, who likes to have a little planner, a little to-do list, whatever you need a notebook for, these ones are adorable. and definitely up there as being one of my favorite things I've ever created. It's also an amazing way to support the show and to support me as a creator. So if you are even thinking about it, thank you so much. And if you hit purchase, you are my favorite person in the world. So without further ado, let's get into the show.
现已上线，大家可以入手了。我们在设计和制作这些播客精美伴侣的过程中倾注了大量的爱与关怀。如果你喜欢写日记，喜欢在听播客时做笔记，喜欢，我不知道，仅仅是一个感恩日记，喜欢有一个小日程本，一个小待办事项清单，无论你需要笔记本做什么，这些都非常可爱。绝对是我创作过最喜欢的物品之一。这也是支持节目以及支持我作为创作者的一种绝佳方式。所以，如果你哪怕只是有这个想法，也非常感谢你。如果你点击购买，你就是全世界我最喜欢的人。闲话少说，让我们进入节目吧。
Today, we are going to be taking a look at one of our most primary and significant emotions, and that is happiness. This huge concept, if we can even call it that, that sounds so reductive to call it a concept, it plays such an everyday valuable role in our life. And yet I realized that I have never actually sat down and done an episode on happiness. Even in 200 episodes, it might come up,
今天，我们将探讨我们最核心、最重要的情绪之一，那就是幸福。这个巨大的概念，如果我们甚至可以称之为概念的话，称它为一个概念听起来太简单化了，它在我们的生活中扮演着日常且宝贵的角色。然而我意识到，我其实从未坐下来做过一期关于幸福的节目。哪怕在两期节目中，它可能会被提及，
but it has never had its time in the spotlight, all on its own. And today is that day when we are going to give all of our attention and focus to this primary, deep, important emotion. I think everybody on this planet wants to be happier in some sense. They want more contentment. They're striving for greater satisfaction in some area of their life, more pleasant emotions, or they recognize that they are unhappy.
但它从未有过属于它自己的聚光灯时间。而今天就是这一天，我们将把所有的注意力和焦点都集中在这项核心、深沉、重要的情绪上。我认为这个星球上的每个人在某种意义上都想变得更快乐。他们想要更多的满足感。他们在努力争取生活各个领域的更大满足感、更多愉悦的情绪，或者他们意识到自己并不快乐。
And they're looking for some way out of their despair or their emotional rut. and yet I don't think many of us really know how to change that. We don't really know what brings us joy or contentment. We kind of spend a lot of our life at this like baseline level, this like 50% mark of not being unhappy, but not really excelling as a happy human. The other alternative is that we spend a lot of time doing things that we think will improve our life satisfaction,
并且他们正在寻找某种摆脱绝望或情绪低谷的方法。然而我认为，我们当中并没有多少人真正知道如何改变现状。我们并不真正知道是什么给我们带来了快乐或满足。我们的生活在很大程度上都处于这种基准水平，也就是既不痛苦、但也没有作为快乐的人真正大放异彩的50%大关。另一种选择是，我们花大量时间去做那些我们认为能提高生活满意度的事情，
doing things that we think bring temporary pleasure and temporary joy, but which don't actually have that sustainable happiness factor behind them, right? They don't actually improve our emotional state in the long term. I'm thinking about things like retail therapy. That's the first one that always comes to mind. But other concepts or other behaviors like binge drinking, emotional eating, yes, we feel better in the moment. Often we use these things to self-soothe, but I think that if we see happiness as a scale,
去做那些我们认为能带来暂时的快乐和短暂的喜悦，但背后其实并没有那种可持续的幸福感因素的事情，对吧？它们实际上并没有从长远上改善我们的情绪状态。我想到了零售疗法。这是我脑海中最先浮现的。但其他概念或其他行为，如暴饮暴食、情绪性进食，是的，我们在当下感觉好多了。我们经常用这些东西来自我安抚，但我认为，如果我们把幸福视为一个刻度，
a lot of those activities that we pursue to improve happiness really don't have a lasting effect. On top of that, I also think that in our minds, for a lot of us, happiness is like important, absolutely, but it's also seen as rather uncomplicated and very much out of our control. When life is good, we are happy. When bad things happen, we are not. And so we really do tend to project our happiness and see it. as the responsibility of our circumstances, the responsibility of what is happening around us.
我们为了提高幸福感而追求的许多活动其实并没有持久的效果。最重要的是，我也认为在我们的脑海中，对许多人来说，幸福很重要，绝对重要，但它也被视为相当简单，而且很大程度上不在我们的掌控之中。生活美好时，我们就会快乐。坏事发生时，我们就不会快乐。因此，我们确实倾向于将幸福投射出去，并将其视为。环境的责任，周围发生的事情的责任。
That is what has the biggest impact. But actually, that is not necessarily the case. There is this model called the Happiness Pi, which says something completely differently. So behavioral geneticists, psychologists, they actually attribute about 50% of our happiness to genetics. So every single one of us is born with what we call happiness set point, a baseline level of happiness.
那才是产生最大影响的因素。但实际上，情况未必如此。有一个名为“幸福饼图”的模型，它说明了完全不同的情况。因此，行为遗传学家、心理学家实际上将我们大约50%的幸福归因于遗传。因此，我们每个人出生时都带有我们所谓的幸福设定点，即幸福的基准水平。
This kind of relates to the individual differences between being a pessimist and being an optimist. When we are born, we are just naturally hardwired to see the world as perhaps realistic, but more so either a brighter or darker place than it actually is. So 50% genetics and then 10% of our happiness comes down to our life circumstances, which is shocking because I think so often we blame our context and external events for our emotional state when actually it really can only tip the scale, not throw it off completely. I think of course, during intense moments of loss or grief that 10% is really going to dominate, but on the average day, our happiness really comes down to our mindset and our outlook and our habits. And so we finally arrived,
这在一定程度上与悲观主义者和乐观主义者之间的个体差异有关。当我们出生时，我们天生就被硬编码为以或许现实的方式看待世界，但更多的是将其视为比实际情况更明亮或更黑暗的地方。因此，50%归因于遗传，然后10%的幸福归因于我们的生活环境，这很令人震惊，因为我认为我们经常将我们的情绪状态归咎于我们的环境和外部事件，而实际上它只能让天平倾斜，而不能彻底打破它。我想当然地认为，在经历强烈的失落或悲伤时刻时，那10%确实会占据主导地位，但在平常的日子里，我们的幸福实际上归结为我们的心态、我们的视野和我们的习惯。所以我们终于迎来了，
at that final slice of the pie, the 40% that we can actually attribute to our personal choices. 40% of our happiness is dictated by us. Science would say that it is within our control. And that's what we're going to focus on today, that part of the equation and five ways that we can scientifically improve our level of happiness. and I really wanted to talk about tips that were actionable, accessible, simple, but also inexpensive, right? I'm not going to recommend some like $50 workout class or supplement because it's kind of ridiculous to think that only wealthy people would have access to joy and peace.
最后一块饼图，即我们可以归因于个人选择的40%。我们40%的幸福是由我们自己决定的。科学会说这是在我们的控制之中的。而这正是我们今天要关注的，即方程式的那一部分，以及我们可以通过科学方式提高幸福水平的五种方法。我真的很想谈谈那些切实可行、触手可及、简单但又成本低廉的建议，对吧？我不会推荐什么50美元的健身课程或补充剂，因为认为只有富有的人才有权获得快乐和平静，这种想法未免太荒谬了。
But I'm also not going to give you like the basic tips that we all know. You know, I think we all understand that when you exercise and move more, when you get eight hours of sleep, when you eat better, you are going to be happier. That is pretty basic knowledge. But I want to go a little bit deeper today. I want to really look at some of the academia and the research about what can really impact our happiness on an everyday level. What are some of the secret habits of really, really joyful, happy, content people?
但我也不会给你那些我们都知道的基本建议。你知道的，我想我们都明白，当你锻炼并增加运动量时，当你保证八小时睡眠时，当你吃得更好时，你会更快乐。那是相当基础的知识。但今天我想更深入一些。我想真正审视一些关于什么才能真正在日常生活中影响我们幸福感的学术研究和调研。那些真正、真正快乐、幸福、知足的人身上有哪些秘密习惯？
One final caveat, I know I've been rambling for a while. These are not tips that are going to, of course, cure you of your mental health concerns. of your mental health symptoms or conditions. They are more so additions to our life. They are techniques that can elevate the work that we're already doing in therapy with the help of medications. I just want to say that loud and clear. This is not a replacement.
最后一个警告，我知道我废话了一段时间。当然，这些建议并不能治愈你的心理健康问题。你的心理健康症状或病症。它们更多的是我们生活的补充。它们是可以提升我们在药物帮助下已经在进行的心理治疗效果的技术。我想大声清晰地说明这一点。这不是替代品。
These are just bonuses. So without further ado, let's get into our five evidence-based ways to actually, truly be happier. 2%. That is the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believed that seed oils were inherently inflammatory.
这些只是红利。废话少说，让我们来看看真正获得幸福的五种循证方法。百分之二。这就是指在有自动扶梯可用时，依然选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特，在我的播客节目“百分之二”中，我将剖析我们这个奇异现代世界中坚韧不拔的意志、健身以及建立心理韧性的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等进行对话，以摆脱主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的相信种子油本质上会引起发炎。
We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's T-W-O-Persent on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tapped Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking.
我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题都是压力的结果。经历一些艰难困苦，你将以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己迎来蜕变。收听“百分之二”。也就是T-W-O-Persent，可在I-Hart Radio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听。你还记得戴安娜·罗斯在VMA颁奖典礼上双击小金的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不喜欢黑人时。我知道你在想什么。
What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast. I'm Sam Jek. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we picket here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 was big to me, not just because of course. crack.
乔治·布什跟小金到底有什么关系？好吧，你可以在Look Back at it播客中找到答案。我是萨姆·杰克。我是亚历克斯·恩格斯。每一期节目中，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试图理解我们是如何熬过来的。包括最近一期与马克·拉蒙特·希尔的节目，畅谈80年代的可卡因。需要明确的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为当然。可卡因。
I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know. I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really?
我随时准备在白天谈论可卡因，但只是为了让你们知道。我的意思是，在这一点上，马克，这是我们讨论可卡因的第二期节目。所以我开始看出有一条贯穿线了。我们现在也把艾滋病摆在桌面上。谢谢你完成那句话。是的。我认为对于黑人来说，没有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？
Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcast. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hardway with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Keer Games. And in recognition of Mental Health Awareness Month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking, Tript Fantine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing.
是的。对我和美国历史上的黑人来说，这是最重要的年份之一。欢迎收听我的新播客《以防万一》，我是你们的主持人、你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯。为了纪念心理健康意识月，我带来了自己在心理健康领域十多年的经验，并与许多令人难以置信的嘉宾进行了对话。我说的是，特里普·凡廷，瑞安·克拉克。有时，当我们追求某样东西时，我们会如此全神贯注于追逐，以至于没有意识到我们已经拥有了这样东西。
And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough. Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth? Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely.
而我们仍在追逐它。我们不知道什么时候才算够了。因为人们在盯着记分牌看。生活变成了关于输赢。史蒂夫·伯恩斯，达斯汀·罗斯，因为你觉得在人间时做一个好人很重要？你做一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为那是两种不同的意图，兄弟。绝对的。
And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person. Join me, Kear Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, learn the hard way. Open your free, our heart radio app. Search learn the hard way and listen now.
那是两个不同信任级别。我希望你真的能成为一个好人。加入我，基尔·盖恩斯，在我的新播客《以防万一》中，就治愈、成长、父爱、压力和目标进行真实的对话。打开你免费的our heart radio应用程序。搜索Learn the Hard Way并立即收听。
In 2023, former bachelor star Clayton Eckerd found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法庭听证会揭示了他故事中明显的矛盾之处。这开启了一场长达数年的诉讼战来证明真相。欧文斯女士，你伪造了这个特定检测两次，对吧？我伪造了一次检测。这花费了一大批互联网侦探才破案。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税被用在了什么地方。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Gregalespian and Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过同样事情的男士。格雷格·莱斯皮安和迈克尔·马拉蒂尼。我的脑子炸裂了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。这是《爱情陷阱》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警察。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is. served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Let us jump straight into it with my first tip. Invest as much time in your platonic relationships as your romantic ones, if not more.
随着节目的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县传来突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被以欺诈罪起诉。在正义得到伸张之前，这一切都不会结束。在亚利桑那州得到伸张。在iHeartRadio应用程序、Apple Podcasts或您获取播客的任何地方收听Love Trapped播客。让我们直接切入我的第一个建议。花在柏拉图式关系（友情）上的时间要和浪漫关系（爱情）一样多，甚至更多。
I think that it is important that if we are focusing on happiness, we need to firstly focus on our social connections. And that requires us to spend at least, I would say, 30. 30 minutes every day, doing something that meaningfully connects you with another person and that keeps you in touch. Even as life gets busy, even as the older we get, you know, the more focus we become on our partners or our romantic lives or our marriages, keep those platonic connections alive with those people from your past and new friends as well, even when it feels hard, even when it feels tedious and dare I say, even when it does sometimes, let's admit it,
我认为重要的是，如果我们专注于幸福，我们首先需要关注我们的社交联系。这需要我们每天至少花，我会说，30。每天30分钟，做一些能让你与另一个人产生有意义联系并保持联系的事情。即使生活变得忙碌，即使我们年龄越大，你知道的，我们越关注我们的伴侣、浪漫生活或婚姻，也要与你过去的人以及新朋友保持这些柏拉图式的联系，即使感觉很难，即使感觉乏味，我敢说，甚至有时，让我们承认这一点，
feel like a bit of a chore. I think we all go through these like social ruts where we want to isolate, where we do feel withdrawn or, you know, just simply lonely. And the best thing that you can do for your happiness is to find some way, any way of getting back in touch with others. That is one of the core needs that we have as human. So let's talk about some of the research behind why this is so crucial and why it's often neglected. So possibly one of the most brilliant and significant studies of all time provides so much evidence for why this is such an important step in our happiness.
感觉像是一件琐事。我认为我们都会经历这样的社交低谷，我们想要孤立自己，感到孤立无援，或者，你知道的，仅仅是感到孤独。你能为你的幸福做的最好的事情就是找到某种方式，任何能与他人重新取得联系的方式。这是我们作为人类的核心需求之一。因此，让我们来谈谈这一切为何如此至关重要以及它为何经常被忽视背后的部分研究。因此，这可能是史上最精彩、最重要的研究之一，它为这何尝不是我们幸福中如此重要的一步提供了大量的证据。
So back in 1938, that is almost 90 years ago now, this huge team at Harvard University, they decided that they wanted to track 268 current. sophomores at the time. And they didn't just want to track them for the, you know, for the year, for the term. They wanted to track them for the rest of their lives, regularly checking in with them, regularly seeing how they were going, to determine what parts of their lives, what factors were, you know, determining whether one person was healthy and one person wasn't, what events and characteristics meant that these men succeeded or failed, what caused their early deaths or their long lives, what made their marriages flourish versus fail. And also, what it was about these people's lives, tracking them from when they were 19 till 90, and even past that, what made these
早在1938年，也就是将近90年前，哈佛大学的这个庞大团队决定追踪当时的268名在校。大二学生。他们不仅仅是想追踪他们一年、一个学期。他们想追踪他们余下的人生，定期跟进，定期了解他们的进展，以确定他们生活的哪些部分、哪些因素决定了一个人是否健康，哪些事件和特征意味着这些男性成功或失败，是什么导致了他们的早逝或长寿，是什么让他们的婚姻蓬勃发展或走向失败。此外，关于这些人的生活，从他们19岁追踪到90岁甚至更久，是什么让这些。
people happy versus miserable? So this is now known as the Grant study. It is actually the longest longitudinal study of all time. When I'm recording this right now, 2024, I think only about like 18 of the men are still alive. But the biggest finding across all of those decades of observation and research was that the one thing that determined happiness above all else was positive social relationships, not money, not promotions or careers, not material possessions, but friendship and love, and even deeper than that, just genuine companionship and a warmth from relationships. There is something really valuable in that that I think we often forget.
这些人感到幸福与痛苦？现在，这被称为格兰特研究。它实际上是史上历时最长的纵向研究。当我此时此刻在2024年录制这个节目时，我想大概只有大约18名男性还活着。但几十年的观察和研究得出的最大发现是，高于一切决定幸福的一件事是积极的社交关系，而不是金钱、不是晋升或职业、不是物质财富，而是友谊和爱情，甚至比这更深层次的，仅仅是真正的陪伴和人际关系中的温暖。这其中蕴含着非常宝贵的价值，我想我们经常忘记这一点。
I think there is often this sense of like friendships and, you know, relationships are just there to feel empty space. They are there to make me feel less lonely. Or we sometimes end up thinking that our careers and material fulfillment is actually what determines our happiness. And this is a bit of a wake-up call that, no, if you are going to invest in anything in your life, anything at all that's going to ensure that not only do you live longer, but you're happier, it is those really meaningful platonic friendships and relationships.
我认为人们经常有一种感觉，即友谊和，你知道的，关系只是为了填补空白。它们是为了让我不那么感到孤独。或者我们有时最终会认为，我们的职业和物质上的满足实际上决定了我们的幸福。这是一个警钟，不，如果你要在你的生活中投资任何东西，任何能确保你不仅活得更长而且更快乐的东西，那就是那些真正有意义的柏拉图式友谊和关系。
That was like the pioneering study on this. There have, of course, been so many follow-up research projects that are finding the exact same thing. Another example of this is a more recent one, and researchers employed the use of this app, and it was called the mappiness app. And basically what they wanted to determine was when are people happiest? On an 11 point scale from No I'm Not Happy at All to I'm Extremely Happy, this app would send them little alerts to rank how they were at that very point throughout their day.
那是关于这一主题的开创性研究。当然，还有许多后续研究项目发现了完全相同的事情。另一个例子是最近的一项研究，研究人员使用了一款名为“幸福感”的应用程序。基本上，他们想确定的是人们什么时候最快乐。在从“不，我一点也不快乐”到“我非常快乐”的11分制量表中，这款应用程序会向他们发送小提醒，让他们对一天中那个特定时刻的状态进行评分。
And they had over 3 million submissions from nearly 50,000 volunteers. And what they found was that the point where people are happiest is when they are with their friends amongst everything else that they were able to track when they were with their partners, when they were with their parents, when they were with their children, when they were at work, when they were exercising, when they were with their friends always came out on top. So applying this tip, here are three things that we can do. Once a day, find 30 minutes minimum to deepen your bond with someone. Literally, it could be as easy as sending them TikToks or texting them.
他们收到了来自近5万名志愿者的300多万条提交数据。他们发现，人们最快乐的时刻是和朋友在一起的时候，在他们能够追踪的所有事情中——当他们和伴侣在一起时，当他们和父母在一起时，当他们和孩子在一起时，当他们在工作时，当他们在锻炼时——和朋友在一起总是高居榜首。因此，应用这个建议，我们可以做三件事。每天，至少留出30分钟来加深你与某人的联系。字面意思，这可以很简单，比如给他们发TikTok或发短信，
but if you really want to improve your chances here, giving that long-distance friend a call or grabbing lunch with a friend on your lunch break, going to the gym together afterwards, you know, after work, those small 30-minute, like, kind of points of contact are so valuable in building up that relationship. Once a week, you need to be doing minimum, at least, a one to two hour, even longer, hopefully, in-depth catch-up,
但如果你真的想在这里提高胜算，给那个远方的朋友打个电话，或者在午休时和朋友一起吃午餐，下班后一起去健身房，你知道的，下班后，这30分钟的小接触点对于建立这种关系非常有价值。每周，你都需要做到最低限度，至少进行一到两个小时，甚至更长时间的深入聚会，
with one of your friends where you actually have a deep, meaningful conversation, you get vulnerable, you disclose, you laugh and more important, you make memories. And then it comes to once a month. Once a month, become the host. Now, if you have listened for a while, if you know me in real life, you will know that one of my secrets to, I would say being an incredibly optimistic happy person and a present person as well is finding ways to build community, not just for myself, but also for the people that I love. And I think hosting events in your house, in your neighbourhood, small things is an expression of that.
与你的一个朋友进行深入、有意义的交谈，变得脆弱，进行自我披露，欢笑，更重要的是，创造回忆。接下来就是每月一次。每月一次，成为东道主。现在，如果你听这个节目有一段时间了，如果你在现实生活中认识我，你就会知道，我的秘诀之一——可以说是成为一个极其乐观、快乐的人和一个活在当下的人——是寻找建立社区的方法，不仅为了我自己，也为了我爱的人。我认为在你的家里、在你的社区举办活动，这些小事就是这种表达。
When I stopped waiting for other people to do or organise cool things and hopefully invite me and just started being the person who literally just did fun shit, my life got so much better. So once a month, what I really would implore you to do, is to get together a big, random bunch of people for like a friendship group potluck or a movie night at somebody's house. Or, you know, trivia, brunch, a run club, you be the organizer, you be the host, you be the person around which community is built. I think, you know, reflecting on that and why it makes so much sense is that in this day and age, we really lack some of the structures. and activities that used to bring us together. You know, in the past, we used to have so many more places to operate within a community, right?
当我停止等待别人去做或组织酷炫的事情并希望邀请我，而是开始成为那个字面意思就是去做有趣事情的人时，我的生活变得好多了。所以每月一次，我真正恳请你做的，是把一大群随机的人聚在一起，举行某种友谊聚餐或者在某个人的家里举办电影之夜。或者，你知道的，智力问答早午餐、跑步俱乐部，你来当组织者，你来当东道主，你成为社区围绕其建立的核心人物。我认为，你知道的，反思这一点以及为什么它如此合乎情理，是因为在当今时代，我们确实缺乏一些曾经将我们凝聚在一起的结构。和活动。你知道的，过去我们在社区内活动的场所要多得多，对吧？
We had community dances. We had town squares. We had small village-like places and spaces where you were surrounded by people. A lot more people went to church or were involved in religion. There was a bigger focus on community, essentially. And I think as society has progressed and become more globalized, but also a lot more online, for example, we've lost a lot of that. And that disconnection really bleeds into other areas of our lives. So deliberately making our way back to that, making engagement a practice rather than something we passively fall into is so valuable.
我们有社区舞会。我们有城镇广场。我们有像小村庄一样的地方和空间，你被人群包围。更多的人去教堂或参与宗教活动。本质上，人们更加关注社区。我认为随着社会的进步和全球化，但也变得更加网络化，例如，我们失去了很多那样的联系。这种断开连接感确实蔓延到了我们生活的其他领域。因此，刻意找回那种状态，将交往变成一种习惯，而不是我们被动陷入的某种状态，是非常宝贵的。
My second tip for today, spend your money better. Now, this has nothing to do with budgeting or having long-term financial goals. It is actually about spending money on others and on experiences. And trust me, I know that in this kind of very materialistic society, this may initially make you feel uncomfortable to hear me say that the secret to happiness is to spend on other people and not yourself, but there is a science here. If you're aiming the happiness, if that is your goal, this might just be the path to it. Money does make us happier up to a point, though, only up to a point.
今天的第二个建议：把钱花得更好。这与预算或拥有长远财务目标无关。这实际上是关于把钱花在别人身上和体验上。相信我，我知道在这个物欲横流的社会里，听到我说幸福的秘诀是把钱花在别人身上而不是自己身上，一开始可能会让你感到不舒服，但这里面是有科学依据的。如果你的目标是幸福，如果那是你的目标，这可能就是通往它的途径。金钱确实让我们更快乐，不过也只是到了一定程度。
So in a really famous study, I think we probably have all heard of at some point. And they actually revised it last year. Basically, they wanted to measure at what point does an extra dollar really not do much for our happiness? At what point does making more money not really move the needle when it comes to how good we feel? And they recently updated this for inflation. And nowadays, what they say is that once you are making around 100K a year in US dollars, so do the conversion if you live outside of the US, more money doesn't really do much to make you feel better.
因此，在一项非常著名的研究中，我想我们可能都在某个时候听说过。他们实际上在去年对其进行了修正。基本上，他们想衡量的是，在什么点上，多出一美元对我们的幸福真的没有多大帮助？在什么点上，赚更多的钱在我们的感觉有多好方面并没有真正起到推动作用？他们最近根据通货膨胀更新了这一点。如今，他们说的是，一旦你每年赚取大约10万美元的美元，所以如果你住在美国境外，请自行换算，更多的钱对让你感觉更好并没有多大帮助。
And it doesn't do much to eliminate misery or sadness. Yes, you might be able to, you know, buy objects and experiences that you value. You definitely will have more freedom and independence and security. But at that point, there isn't much more that would provide you with already that baseline. So if your happiness hasn't already been influenced by that level of wealth, more money isn't going to help you. But there's something else that will. So a study by Harvard Business School and the University of British Columbia, they found that once you've actually pulled yourself out of poverty,
它对消除痛苦或悲伤也没有多大帮助。是的，你或许能够购买你珍视的物品和体验。你肯定会拥有更多的自由、独立和安全感。但在那个时候，并没有太多其他东西能够提供给你已经拥有的基准。因此，如果你的幸福还没有受到那种财富水平的影响，更多的钱也帮不了你。但还有别的东西可以。因此，哈佛商学院和不列颠哥伦比亚大学的一项研究发现，一旦你真正摆脱了贫困，
so once you can actually afford your basics, spending money on other people actually gives us more joy than spending money on ourselves. So they found that even a minimal amount can make a difference. It's really interesting because I think that that power of generosity has been lost, but it is such ancient, ancient knowledge. I think in almost every major religion, every major historical text, you will find evidence that for a long time we've known that doing good by other people makes us feel better.
所以一旦你真正买得起基本生活用品，把钱花在别人身上实际上比把钱花在我们自己身上能带给我们更多的快乐。因此他们发现，即使是极少量的钱也能产生影响。这真的很有趣，因为我认为慷慨的力量已经丧失了，但这是非常古老、非常古老的知识。我认为在几乎每一个主要宗教、每一部主要的历代史料中，你都会发现证据，证明长期以来我们一直都知道，对别人做好事会让我们感觉更好。
I think it also has the effect of turning the attention away from you and your problems for a moment and remembering what it is that you have that others might not, that you could assist them by giving to them. So use your money, devote some portion of it to basically engaging in random acts of kindness. Quite literally, I want you to budget it in. One way that I do this is called Good Deed Sunday. Every Sunday you practice essentially being generous. You give back in some way or another.
它也有将注意力从你和你的问题上移开片刻的效果，让你想起你拥有而别人可能没有的东西，你可以通过给予来帮助他们。所以利用你的金钱，将其一部分专门用于基本上从事随机的善举。字面意思，我想让你把它做成预算。我这样做的一种方法叫做“善举星期日”。每个星期天，你基本上都要练习慷慨。你以这样或那样的方式回馈社会。
It actually doesn't even need to be that much. It could be that, you know, when you go and do your weekly shop, you buy some extra items for your local community pantry. Or you ask somebody doing it tough outside if you can buy them something. If you can buy them a couple of items that they really need. You could find a, you know, random go fund me and budget literally $5, $10, $15 each week to go towards this random act of giving back and kindness. I know it feels kind of strange giving to others for your own. happiness rather than just because you feel compelled to do so. But I actually think it's more about adopting an attitude and a genuine lifestyle, adversely gratitude for what you do have and generosity
其实甚至不需要那么多。可能是，你知道的，当你去进行每周购物时，你为当地的社区食品储藏室购买一些额外的物品。或者你问问外面那个生活艰难的人，是否可以给他们买点什么。如果你能给他们买几样他们真正需要的物品。你可以找到一个，你知道的，随机的众筹项目，每周预算仅仅5美元、10美元、15美元用于这种随机的回馈和善举。我知道为了你自己的幸福而不是仅仅因为你觉得有义务这样做而给予别人，感觉有点奇怪。但我实际上认为这更多的是关于采纳一种态度和真正的生活方式，对你所拥有的东西的反向感恩和慷慨。
by realizing that there is so much that you could give to others that you should essentially feel really privileged to already be in possession of. And as I said, the studies repeatedly say you will feel better for it. You will feel so much better. giving that small portion of what you're making to somebody else than using it to buy something that you might not actually need. So a brief second layer to this tip around spending your money better to promote your happiness. If you're not spending that extra coinage on others, if that's not really what you want to do with your time and your money, that is okay.
通过意识到有这么多东西你可以给予别人，你应该基本上为自己已经拥有这些感到非常荣幸。正如我所说，研究一再表明，你会为此感觉更好。你会感觉好得多。把你的收入的一小部分给别人，而不是用它去买一件你可能并不真正需要的东西。因此，关于把钱花得更好以促进幸福这一建议的第二个简短层面。如果你没有把多余的硬币花在别人身上，如果那并不是你真正想用你的时间和金钱做的事情，那也没关系。
A study by Cornell University found that you were actually better off purchasing experiences than things. because the joy and the satisfaction that you get from an object is going to wane and decline pretty quickly after purchasing, but the enjoyment of an experience, it's like a nice wine. It gets better over time. As you age, those memories do become more valuable. They become an investment. They become an important asset.
康奈尔大学的一项研究发现，购买体验实际上比购买物品对你更有益。因为你从一件物品中获得的喜悦和满足感在购买后会很快减弱和下降，但对一种体验的享受，它就像一杯好酒。它会随着时间推移变得更好。随着你年龄的增长，这些记忆确实会变得更有价值。它们成为了一项投资。它们成为了一项重要的资产。
The other thing that the researchers pointed out around this in this study by Cornell was that your experiences are actually just inherently less comparative. It's a lot harder to, you know, compare them to somebody else and feel like you're lacking the same way that we can do with material objects. And we also don't typically have buyers remorse when it comes to memories, when it comes to experiences, because even if they were terrible, they are still a story. So if you want to spend your money better for your happiness, give to others, and give to your memories rather than to your kind of like material rather than to the material side of things.
研究人员围绕这一点在这项康奈尔大学的研究中指出的另一件事是，你的体验实际上本质上更不具比较性。你很难，你知道的，把它们与别人的进行比较，并觉得你有所欠缺，就像我们对待物质物品那样。而且当涉及到记忆、涉及到体验时，我们通常不会有买家悔恨，因为即使它们很糟糕，它们仍然是一个故事。因此，如果你想为了幸福而把钱花得更好，那就给予别人，并给予你的记忆，而不是物质层面，而不是事物的那一面。
So let's move on to our third tip. Have one project, one thing that you are actively trying to finish or accomplish or get better at. I say this a lot on the podcast, so I'm very sorry if I sound like a broken record at this point, but I say it because it's important and it's something that. that I believe in very deeply, sometimes the easiest thing to do isn't what's best for us. What's best for us is the thing that requires a bit more effort for a lot more gain. I think the older we get, we do tend to become more passive in our lives, especially during our free time, during our downtime, because hours along, life is exhausting, life is busy,
所以让我们转向我们的第三个建议。拥有一个项目，一件你正在积极尝试完成、达成或做得更好的事情。我在播客中经常这么说，所以如果我此时听起来像个复读机，我非常抱歉，但我之所以这么说，是因为这很重要，而且这是。我非常深信不疑的事情，有时最容易做的事情并不最适合我们。最适合我们的事情是需要付出更多努力以换取更多收获的事情。我认为随着我们年龄的增长，我们在生活中确实往往变得更被动，特别是在我们的空闲时间、我们的停机时间里，因为时间很长，生活令人筋疲力尽，生活很忙碌，
everything just gets a bit harder. I think we have all had that feeling. some point of just wanting to take the path of least resistance through life, getting home from work and just genuinely wanting to sit on the couch and scroll. But when we were kids, when we were teenagers, we often had the privilege of something to work towards, something that actually gave us a sense of drive and purpose. I think that we have lost that a little bit now. And, you know, everybody tries to blame social media and technology. I'm going to actually quickly jump on that bandwagon for a second.
一切都变得有点难。我想我们都有过这种感觉。在某个时刻，只想在生活中选择阻力最小的路线，下班回家，真心地只想坐在沙发上刷手机。但当我们还是孩子、还是青少年时，我们经常有幸拥有一些值得努力的目标，一些真正给我们带来动力和目标感的东西。我认为我们现在稍微失去了这一点。而且，你知道的，每个人都试图把这归咎于社交媒体和技术。我实际上要快速赶上这股潮流一会儿。
I think with social media, if we're getting the same amount of dopamine from saying other people do cool and rewarding stuff, why would we need to do it ourselves? And the reason why, the answer to that question is that we need purpose. If we think about happiness as being made up of four components, in my mind they would be joy and pleasure. connection, altruism, and meaning, doing something that actually makes you feel like you are alive and contributing and just having a sense of purpose. So in 2013, this group of researchers at UCLA, they actually identified this through some research they were doing on the two distinct kinds of happiness. We have hedonic happiness and eudamonic happiness. Hopefully I pronounce that right, eudamonic. Yeah, eudamonic happiness. There we go. Correct me if I'm wrong. But hedonic happiness
我认为在社交媒体上，如果我们从看别人做酷炫且有回报的事情中获得了相同数量的多巴胺，我们为什么还要自己去做呢？而那个原因，那个问题的答案是，我们需要目标。如果我们认为幸福由四个组成部分构成，在我看来，它们将是快乐与愉悦。连接、利他主义和意义，做一些真正让你觉得自己活着、在做贡献并且有目标感的事情。因此，在2013年，加州大学洛杉矶分校的一组研究人员实际上通过他们对两种不同幸福感的研究确定了这一点。我们有享乐主义的幸福（Hedonic）和实现潜能的幸福（Eudaimonic）。希望我发音正确，实现潜能的幸福。是的，实现潜能的幸福。就是这样。如果我错了，请纠正我。但享乐主义的幸福
comes from self-gratification and pleasure seeking. Hedonic is obviously relating to the idea of hedonism, prioritizing pleasure over everything else. But eutemonic happiness comes from having a deep sense of meaning and purpose in life, doing things for others, but more so doing hard things that do take time rather than getting all of your joy and pleasure from instantly gratifying experiences. We tend to spend a lot of time in hedonic happiness. We look to external pleasures to make life enjoyable because eutonic happiness is harder. Simply put, it's just harder to obtain. But there are so many benefits. So simply put, if you are in a bit of an emotional rut right now, I think creating meaning is an essential way to switch from adonic happiness to udonic happiness,
来自自我满足和追求快乐。享乐主义显然与享乐主义的概念有关，即把快乐置于一切之上。但实现潜能的幸福来自于生活中对意义和目标的深刻感受，为他人做事，但更多的是做需要时间而不是从即时满足的体验中获得所有快乐和愉悦的艰难事情。我们倾向于花很多时间在享乐主义的幸福中。我们期待外部的快乐来使生活变得愉快，因为实现潜能的幸福更难。简而言之，它只是更难获得。但有这么多的好处。因此，简而言之，如果你现在正处于某种情绪低谷中，我认为创造意义是从享乐主义幸福转变为实现潜能幸福的基本途径，
just have a little bit more of that more sustainable form of joy in your life. And we create that meaning by creating goals or things that we can strive towards. because I think it, you know, in that act of striving, we feel engaged and proactive, meaning we realize that we can do things to change our lives and how we feel about it. Now, those goals, this big, very daunting idea of purpose, it doesn't have to be as large or as scary as it sounds, you just need to have something. and I prefer to think about this as a project rather than thinking about this huge mission that we all need to have. You just need to have something.
让你的生活中多一点那种更具可持续性的快乐形式。我们通过设定目标或我们可以努力去实现的事情来创造意义。因为我认为它，你知道的，在那种奋斗的行为中，我们感到专注和积极主动，这意味着我们意识到我们可以做些事情来改变我们的生活以及我们对它的感觉。现在，这些目标，这个宏大、令人望而生畏的目标的概念，不必像听起来那么宏大或可怕，你只需要有某种东西。我更愿意把它看作是一个项目，而不是把它看作是我们所有人都需要完成的这个巨大使命。你只需要有某种东西。
For some people that is, you know, running a marathon, perfect example and also super timely because I think everybody I know right now seems to be training for a marathon or some running event of some sort. But, you know, that's fabulous because you're working towards something that is harder and bigger than yourself that you actually can't achieve overnight. but I also, you know, have a really good friend whose purposeful thing for the year is hitting her 52 book target on goodreads. My dad, for example, right now is learning Japanese. You know, that is something that you progress towards. And for me, well, it was finishing my book, but that is done. So now it's kind of being consistent at the gym, right? I can't just, like, show up one day and, you know, hit all my PRs and do everything perfectly. It is once again, the active striving that is so, so meaningful in these situations.
对某些人来说，你知道，比如跑马拉松，这就是个完美的例子，而且也非常应景，因为我觉得我认识的每个人现在似乎都在训练准备跑马拉松或者参加某种跑步活动。但是呢，这太棒了，因为你在为一件比你自己更艰难、更宏大、而且你无法一蹴而就的事情而努力。不过，你知道的，我还有一个非常要好的朋友，她今年的目标是在Goodreads上读完52本书。比如我父亲，他现在正在学日语。你知道，这是你在不断取得进展的事情。对我来说呢，是写完我的书，但这已经完成了。所以现在就是要保持去健身房的规律性，对吧？我不能只是，比如说，有一天突然出现，然后，你知道的，打破我所有的个人纪录，把什么都做到完美。这再次说明，在这些情况下，这种积极的奋斗才是真正非常有意义的。
So just stop and pause with me right now, and I want you to honestly ask yourself, is there something in my life, anything that is challenging me or that I am working towards? Do I have a project? Or when I finish work, when I finish uni, when I say goodbye to all my friends, is my only function to scroll and consume. And is that really what I was designed to do? Is that really how I want to spend my life? Does it make me feel human?
所以，现在请和我一起停下来，暂停一下，我希望你诚实地问问自己：我的生活中是不是有什么事情，有什么在挑战我或者我在为之努力的事情？我有没有什么项目？还是说，当我下班后，当我大学毕业后，当我跟所有的朋友道别后，我唯一的日常就是刷手机和消费？这真的是我被设计出来的目的吗？这真的是我想度过一生的方式吗？这会让我觉得自己像个人吗？
Does it make you feel meaningful? You can still, of course, unwind in that way, but I just want to encourage you to think about what else you are made for and whether you actually would be happier if you were putting time into something that you really had something to show for it at the end of it all. You really had something that you felt was important and that you felt proud of. All righty, I have two more tips for you, but firstly, we are going to take a small break and then we will be right back. Two percent. That is the number of people who take the stairs
这会让你觉得有意义吗？当然，你还是可以用那种方式放松，但我只是想鼓励你去想想，你生来是为了做什么，如果你把时间投入到一件最终能让你有所成就的事情上，你是不是真的会更快乐。你真的做出了一件你觉得很重要、并且感到骄傲的事情。好了，我还有两个建议要分享给大家，但首先，我们要休息一小会儿，马上回来。百分之二。这就是选择走楼梯的人数比例
when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter, and on my podcast, 2%, I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. I'll be speaking with writers, researchers, and other health and fitness experts, and more, to look past the impractical and way too complex pseudoscience that dominates the wellness industry. We really believe that seed oils were inherently inflammatory. We got it wrong. Many of the problems that we are freaked out about in the world are the result of stress. Put yourself through some hardships.
在旁边也有自动扶梯的情况下。我是迈克尔·伊斯特（Michael Easter），在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。我将与作家、研究人员以及其他健康和健身专家等展开对话，带大家看透主导健康产业的不切实际且过于复杂的伪科学。我们真的曾以为种子油本身就会引起炎症。我们弄错了。我们在世界上感到恐慌的许多问题，其实都是压力的结果。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，
and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%. That's TWO% on the I-Hart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Do you remember when Diana Ross double-tap Little Kim's boobs at the VMAs? Or when Kanye said that George Bush didn't like black people. I know what you're thinking. What the hell does George Bush got to do with Little Kim? Well, you can find out on the Look Back at it podcast.
然后你就会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。也就是在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方搜索“TWO%”。你还记得黛安娜·罗斯（Diana Ross）在VMA颁奖典礼上拍打小金（Lil' Kim）的胸部吗？或者当坎耶说乔治·布什不关心黑人时。我知道你在想什么。乔治·布什他妈的和金姆有什么关系？好吧，你可以在《回顾过去》（Look Back at It）播客中找到答案。
I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick it here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it. Including a recent episode with Mark Lamont Hill, waxing all about crack in the 80s. To be clear, 84 is big to me, not just because of crack. I'm down to talk about crack on day, but just so y'all know.
我是萨姆·J（Sam J.）。我是亚历克斯·英格利什（Alex English）。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。其中包括最近一集请来了马克·拉蒙特·希尔（Mark Lamont Hill），畅谈80年代的快克可卡因。需要说明的是，84年对我很重要，不仅仅是因为快克。我随时都可以聊聊快克，不过就是想让你们都知道。
I mean, at this point, Mark, this is the second episode where we've discussed crack. So I'm starting to see that there's a through line. We also have AIDS on the table right now. Thank you for finishing that sentence. Yes. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Really? Yeah. For me, it's one of the most important years for black people in American history.
我的意思是，马克，到目前为止，这是我们第二集讨论快克了。所以我开始看出这其中有一条贯穿始终的线索了。我们现在还把“艾滋病”摆上台面了。谢谢你把话说完。是的。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。真的吗？是的。对我来说，这是美国历史上对黑人而言最重要的年份之一。
Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome to my new podcast, Learn the Hard Way with me, your host, and your favorite therapist, Kear Games. And in recognition of mental health awareness month, I'm bringing over a decade of my own experience in the mental health field and conversations with so many incredible guests. I'm talking. Trip Fontaine, Ryan Clark. Sometimes when we're in the pursuit of the thing, we get so wrapped up in the chase that we don't realize that we are in possession of the thing. And we're still chasing it. And we don't know when we've done enough.
在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或您获取播客的任何地方收听《Look Back at It》。欢迎来到我的新播客《硬核领悟》（Learn the Hard Way），我是你们的主持人，也是你们最喜欢的治疗师基尔·盖恩斯（Kear Gaines）。为了庆祝心理健康意识月，我将把我在心理健康领域十多年的经验以及与众多不可思议的嘉宾的对话带给大家。我说的是...特里普·方丹（Trip Fontaine）、瑞安·克拉克（Ryan Clark）。有时当我们执着于追求某样东西时，我们会过于深陷于追逐的过程中，以至于没有意识到我们其实已经拥有了它。而我们还在继续追逐。而且我们不知道什么时候才算足够。
Because people scoreboard watch. Life becomes about wins and losses. Steve Burns, Dustin Ross, because you find it important to be a good person while you hear on earth. Are you a good person because you're afraid? Because that's two different intentions, bro. Absolutely. And that's two different levels of trust. I want you to just really be a good person.
因为人们总是在看记分牌。生活变成了关于赢输的游戏。史蒂夫·伯恩斯（Steve Burns）、达斯汀·罗斯（Dustin Ross），因为你觉得在这个世界上当一个好人很重要。你成为一个好人是因为你害怕吗？因为这是两种不同的动机，兄弟。绝对的。而且这是两个不同层面的信任。我希望你能真正地做一个好人。
Join me, Keer Gaines, as we have real conversations about healing, growth, fatherhood, pressure, and purpose on my new podcast, Learn the Hardway. Open your free Our Heart Radio app. Search Learn the Hardway and listen now. In 2023, former Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd
加入我的新播客《Learn the Hard Way》，和基尔·盖恩斯一起，就治愈、成长、父亲身份、压力和人生目标展开真实的对话。打开免费的iHeartRadio App。搜索“Learn the Hard Way”并立即收听。在2023年，前《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德（Clayton Eckerd）
found himself at the center of a paternity scandal. The family court hearings that followed revealed glaring inconsistencies in her story. This began a years-long court battle to prove the truth. You doctored this particular test twice in so-ins, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to crack the case. I wanted people to be able to see what their tax dollars were being used for.
发现自己处于一场亲子鉴定丑闻的中心。随后的家庭法院听证会揭露了她说法中明显的前后矛盾。这就引发了长达数年的法庭之战来证明真相。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一群互联网侦探来破解这个案件。我希望人们能够看到他们的纳税都被用在了哪里。
Sunlight's the greatest disinfected. They would uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Alesspian, Michael Marantini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young. This is Love Trap. Laura, Scottsdale Police.
阳光是最好的消毒剂。他们将揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男士。格雷格·阿莱斯皮安（Greg Alesspian）、迈克尔·马兰蒂尼（Michael Marantini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨（Stephanie Young）。这是《深陷爱河》（Love Trap）。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。
As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Ladies and gentlemen, breaking news at Americopa County as Laura Owens has been indicted on fraud charges. This isn't over until justice is served in Arizona. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Welcome back. I have two final tips for you today. And the first one takes place. outdoors. If you want to be happier, if that is what you are striving towards, and I'm assuming that it is, because you are listening to this episode, you need to rewild yourself. You need to
随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。女士们先生们，马里科帕县的突发新闻，劳拉·欧文斯已被起诉欺诈罪。在亚利桑那州伸张正义之前，这一切都不会结束。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。欢迎回来。今天我还有最后两个建议要送给大家。第一个建议发生在户外。如果你想更快乐，如果这就是你所追求的目标，而且我猜是的，因为你正在听这一集节目，你需要回归自然。你需要
quite literally touch some grass. Get your feet stuck in the dirt. You know, experience awe as you look at the stars. Take a dive in the ocean. Pretty much anything that gets you connected with nature, our literal, you know, natural habitat can boost serotonin. Be on. even some of the strongest antidepressants. Now, again, not a cure for serious mental health concerns. I am never going to sit here and say, go off your medication and, like, get outdoors because I think that is ludicrous, that is ridiculous, that is unethical to even suggest. But it is an important addition.
字面意义上去接触一些草地。让你的双脚陷入泥土中。你知道，在仰望星空时体验敬畏。去海洋里潜水。几乎任何能让你与大自然——我们字面意义上的自然栖息地——建立连接的事情，都能促进血清素的分泌。甚至超过一些最强效的抗抑郁药。当然，再次声明，这并不是严重心理健康问题的治愈方法。我绝不会坐在这里说，停掉你的药，然后去户外吧，因为我觉得这太荒谬了，太可笑了，甚至提出这样的建议都是不道德的。但这是一个重要的补充。
I think we are so detached from nature in today's world. We are so, like, you know, caught up in concrete and indoor environments. that we have lost touch with what makes us wild and what makes us as a species, what makes us connected to the world around us. And when researchers have deliberately intervened and essentially force people to go outdoors as part of studies, the impact on their overall happiness, on their eudonic happiness, on their joy, on their genuine joy and love for life, the results and the impact of that is just honestly so impressive.
我觉得在当今世界，我们与大自然的脱节太严重了。我们太过于深陷于混凝土和室内环境中，以至于我们失去了与那些让我们成为野性生物、让我们作为一个物种与周围世界保持连接的事物的联系。当研究人员刻意干预并实质上强迫人们作为研究的一部分走到户外时，这对他们整体幸福感、享乐主义幸福感、快乐，以及他们对生活由衷的快乐和热爱的巨大影响，真的是让人印象极其深刻。
So I have three examples for you to take away with you today, three examples of how we can really activate this part of us that responds so well to nature. So in 2017, there was a study on this, and it was run on a group of 38 Northern Californians. So not a huge sample size, but just hear me out. So these 38 Californians, sorry, northern Californians, maybe there is a distinction, I don't know, They were split up into two groups. One group took a 90-minute walk in nature every day, and the other group did that same walk in the city.
所以我今天带了三个例子分享给大家，这三个例子展示了我们如何真正激活体内对大自然反应极佳的那部分本能。在2017年，曾有过一项关于这方面的研究，对象是一群38名北加州人。样本量不算大，但请听我道来。这38个加州人——抱歉，是北加州人，也许这之间有什么区别，我不知道——他们被分成了两组。一组每天在大自然中散步90分钟，另一组在城市里进行同样的散步。
At the end of this study, have a guess who was having fewer negative thoughts, have a guess who had a better self-esteem, have a guess who was reporting greater levels of happiness. It was the people who were walking in the outdoors. The urban walkers who were walking amongst the city did not report the same significant amount of change. When they kind of controlled for the general serotonin and endorphin boost from exercise,
在这项研究结束时，猜猜谁的负面想法更少，猜猜谁的自尊心更好，猜猜谁报告的幸福感水平更高。是在户外散步的人。在城市中穿行的都市步行者并没有报告出同样显著的变化量。当他们控制了运动带来的总体血清素和内啡肽提升这一变量后，
it was those who did it out in nature and who were, you know, actively rewilding themselves who really experienced the most benefit. What's more, fMRI scans revealed less activity in the brain region that plays a role in mood disorders and negative thought patterns. These individuals had genuinely seen their brains almost rewire to be more positive. So the dirt example I gave before, you know, it may have sounded like a joke, me telling you to go out and touch some dirt, you know, touch some dirt and there you go, willy-nilly, you're happier.
那些在大自然中进行、并且积极回归自然的人，才真正体验到了最大的益处。不仅如此，fMRI（功能性磁共振成像）扫描显示，大脑中与情绪障碍和消极思维模式相关的区域活动减少了。这些人的大脑确实几乎实现了“重新布线”，变得更加积极。所以我之前举的泥土的例子，你知道听起来可能像个笑话，我让你出去摸摸土，你知道，摸摸土然后你就随随便便变快乐了。
But there is actually some evidence that the literal smell of mud, of dirt may lift your spirits. So what it comes down to is actually this harmless bacteria that exists in the soil. It's called myobacterium vacay. So if you want to give that, you know, fancy Latin name a quick Google, what you're going to find is that when you smell dirt, that smell that you can remember right now, really picture it smelling that like that fresh soil. What you're actually spelling and is that specific bacteria. and when it enters your olfactory center in your brain,
但实际上确实有一些证据表明，泥土、土壤的气密本身可能就能振奋你的精神。所以归根结底，其实是存在于土壤中的一种无害细菌。它被称为散枝分枝杆菌（Mycobacterium vaccae）。如果你想去谷歌一下这个花哨的拉丁名称，你会发现，当你闻到泥土时——那种你现在就能想起来的气味，真的去想象闻到那种新鲜泥土的气味——你实际闻到的是那种特定的细菌。当它进入你大脑的嗅觉中心时，
it releases a whole wave of euphoria and serotonin, so much so that in human tests, when cancer patients were administered this bacteria, their mood, despite their circumstances, despite this terrible, terrible disease, their outlook greatly improved. It is like nature's antidepressant. this bacteria, it is really, you should Google it. It has this strange impact on our brain and how our
它会释放出一整波的欣快感和血清素，以至于在人体试验中，当癌症患者被施用这种细菌时，他们的情绪——尽管身处逆境，尽管患有这种可怕可怕的疾病——其前景得到了极大改善。这就像是大自然自带的抗抑郁药。这种细菌，真的很神奇，你应该去谷歌一下。它对我们的大脑以及我们的
neurons communicate. Even anecdotally, I don't think I've ever met an unhappy person who was gardening. I have never been miserable whilst repotting my plants or hiking or taking my feet off and like squishing them around in the mud. So one final study to convince you of the healing power of the outdoors and why if you are prioritizing happiness, you should be prioritizing quite literally your outdoor time, is this study that was focused on what eating outdoors can do for our well-being. And it turns out that it can do quite a bit. One thing that I hear a lot, and I think it's super understandable, is that, you know, I just don't have time for that.
神经元如何交流有着这种奇异的影响。甚至从个人经验来看，我好像从来没遇到过一个不快乐的园丁。我在重新给植物换盆、远足或者脱下鞋子在泥地里踩来踩去的时候，从来没有痛苦过。所以最后还有一个研究，可以用来向你证明户外疗愈的力量，以及为什么如果你把幸福放在首位，你就应该字面意义上把户外时间放在首位，这项研究关注的是在户外进食能为我们的福祉带来什么。事实证明，它确实能带来相当大的改变。我经常听到的一种说法，而且我觉得这非常可以理解，那就是，你知道，我就是没有时间做那个。
And that is actually so reasonable. If you are working from 8 a.m. to 6 p.m. and it's the middle of winter and the sun is you know, not even coming up until you're at work, not even setting until you're home. How are you possibly meant to, you know, go play in the dirt or frolic in the ocean? How are you meant to do that? I understand, you know, it's really difficult for me to sit here and, you know, give you this advice when we are like, there's just practicalities that prevent me from doing this. So the simple solution is spending your lunch break, that 30 minutes or hour lunch break
这其实非常合乎情理。如果你从早上8点工作到晚上6点，正值隆冬时节，太阳甚至在你上班前还没升起，等你回家时太阳甚至已经落山了。你怎么可能去泥地里玩耍或者在海里嬉戏呢？你怎么可能做到这一点呢？我理解，你知道，我坐在这里给你这个建议真的很困难，因为我们面临着一些现实因素，阻碍了我这样做。所以简单的解决方案就是利用你的午休时间，那30分钟或一个小时的午休时间——
that we all legally get eating outside or eating somewhere with windows to at least see some kind of nature. Do not sit at your desk and eat. Please and thank you. Do not sit, you know, in the middle of a crowded food hall with no natural light and expect, you know, to see a difference. So in 2013, another study for you guys and full of them today. These scientists from the University of Sussex, they measured the happiness of
我们所有人合法拥有的午休时间——在户外吃饭，或者在有窗户的地方吃饭，至少能看到某种大自然。请不要坐在办公桌前吃饭。拜托了谢谢。不要坐在光线不足、拥挤不堪的美食广场中央，还指望能看到什么改变。所以在2013年，又有一项研究分享给大家，今天全是研究。萨塞克斯大学（University of Sussex）的这些科学家们，他们测量了
this group of employees who ate lunch in different locations. So the results showed that workers, they were actually happiest when they ate their lunch on the beach. Of course you're going to be happy doing that. But it's also not reasonable that you can get from your office to the ocean so quickly. But even just getting outside in the sun was a huge contributor to basically like staving off misery. People who ate in parks, people who ate outdoors, they had a more positive attitude about their jobs, about their lives, about their connections
这群在不同地点吃午饭的员工的幸福感。结果显示，工人们在海滩上吃午饭时实际上是最快乐的。你这样做当然会快乐。但你不可能这么快从办公室赶到海滨，这也是不现实的。不过，哪怕只是去户外的阳光下，也是基本上能“驱散悲伤”的巨大助力。那些在公园里吃饭的人，在户外吃饭的人，他们对工作、对生活、对人际关系的态度，
than those who were eating at a restaurant or sitting on their couch at home. So if you want to be happier, even slightly, if this is something you're consciously trying to do, prioritize your outdoor time, that one change that you can make is literally just sitting outside while you have your lunch. something that you are already, you know, it's already factored in your day that you will have to do this. I am going to finish up with my most counterintuitive tip of this entire episode. One that you will probably be surprised would show up in an episode about happiness. Here it is.
都要比那些在餐厅吃饭或坐在家里沙发上的人更加积极。所以如果你想更快乐一点，哪怕只是一点点，如果这是你有意识在努力去做的事情，请优先保证你的户外时间。你可以做出的一个改变，字面意义上就是在吃午饭时坐在户外。这是你本来就已经，你知道的，已经算进你日程里的、你必须要去做的事情。我将以整集节目中最具反直觉的一个建议来做结尾。这个建议你大概会惊讶它怎么会出现在一期关于幸福的节目里。就是这个。
You need to be sadder more often. And let me explain why. We often think of happiness as the absence of sadness. But it's actually a mastery of sadness. It is a recognition that shit happens. Life sometimes hurts a lot. It is boring. It can quite frankly be a little bit bland if we're not searching for hedonistic pleasure at all times.
你需要更频繁地感到悲伤。让我来解释一下原因。我们经常认为幸福就是没有悲伤。但实际上，幸福是对悲伤的掌控。是对“破事总会发生”的认同。生活有时会带来很多痛苦。它很无聊。如果我们不时刻寻求享乐主义的快乐，它坦白说可能会显得有点平淡。
But that doesn't mean that it's not worthwhile. And it also doesn't mean that we suppress those feelings and adopt the delusion that everything is fine and hope that it will be. We need to give ourselves permission to wallow. We need to be tender. We need to feel. We need to watch that sad movie. We need to let ourselves be open about our emotions.
但这并不意味着它不值得。这也不意味着我们要压抑这些感受，并抱有一种“一切都很好”的妄想，然后寄希望于它真的会变好。我们需要允许自己放纵宣泄。我们需要保持柔情。我们需要去感受。我们需要看那部悲伤的电影。我们需要坦然面对自己的情绪。
There is a brilliant Vice article about this back when Vice, you know, was actually good. And it's called You'll Be Happier if you let yourself feel like crap. And I would really, really recommend you go and read it. We have such high standards when it comes. to our emotions like joy, like euphoria, like excitement, like passion, like love. We of course want to feel them all the time. That is so human to want to feel amazing all the time. But it can create a gap between expectation versus reality.
Vice（前卫杂志）以前登过一篇关于这的精彩文章，就在Vice还算不错的那个时期。文章标题叫《如果你允许自己感觉像坨狗屎，你会更快乐》（You'll Be Happier if you let yourself feel like crap）。我真的非常非常推荐你去读一读。我们在对待情绪时标准太高了。对于喜悦、欣快感、兴奋、激情、爱。我们当然希望无时无刻都感受到它们。渴望一直感觉好极了，这是再人性不过的事情了。但这会在期望与现实之间制造一道鸿沟。
And, you know, that actually results in us sometimes feeling less happy overall because we're disappointed that we can't feel happy all the time. And I think, you know, we live in a time when our culture is very obsessed with this idea of constant happiness. And I know it is so ironic that I am doing a whole episode devoted on this feeling whilst I am saying that. But seriously, I do think that maturing and developing and evolving is knowing that you cannot be happy all the time. And this author, Tabor to Bore, that is their full name. She published a study in 23, talking about how. When we as individuals rebrand sadness as valuable rather than as something that we want to escape from,
而且，你知道，这实际上会导致我们有时整体上感觉不那么快乐，因为我们对自已无法时刻感到快乐而感到失望。并且我认为，你知道，我们生活在一个文化非常痴迷于“持续快乐”这一概念的时代。我知道我在说这番话的同时，做了一整期专门探讨这种感觉的节目，这实在是太讽刺了。但说真的，我的确认为走向成熟、不断发展和进化，就意味着你明白自己不可能永远快乐。这位名叫塔博·托博雷（Tabor to Bore）的作家——这确实是她的全名——她在23年发表了一项研究，探讨了这样一个观点：当我们作为个体，把悲伤重新定义为一种有价值的东西，而不是一种我们想要逃避的东西时，
this transformation occurs because the very expression of this emotion begins to normalize it as part of our human condition. And instead of only focusing on how it is maladaptive, how it is unpleasant, how we want to avoid it, we think about what it actually can give us. I think that our ability to embrace our negative feelings provide so many benefits. There have been so many papers on this, so much evidence that people, individuals, like you and I, who accept all of our emotions without judgment, we are less likely to ruminate on, you know, those hard times. We are less likely to suppress mental experiences, you know, which typically backfires to
这种转变就会发生，因为这种情绪的自然表达开始将其规范化，使其成为我们人类境况的一部分。我们不再只关注它是适应不良的、是不愉快的、是我们想要避开的，而是去思考它实际上能带给我们什么。我认为我们拥抱负面情绪的能力提供了如此多的好处。有太多的论文和证据表明，像你我这样不加评判地接受所有情绪的个体，我们更少去反刍那些艰难的时光。我们更少去压抑心理体验——这通常会适得其反，
only amplify those experiences in the end. And we are also less likely to experience meta-emotional reactions, which is feeling, you know, upset about being upset, feeling even more unhappy about the fact that we are unhappy. You know, there was this fabulous article, it's in the Journal of Personality and Social Psychology, and the authors put it this way, when we accept versus judge our mental experience, we let those experiences, you know, experiences run their natural and also relatively short-lived course rather than focusing on them and exacerbating them. So that's my final tip.
最终只会放大那些体验。而且我们也不太可能经历元情绪反应（meta-emotional reactions），也就是对感到沮丧感到沮丧，对感到不快乐感到更加不快乐。你知道，有一篇极棒的文章，发表在《人格与社会心理学杂志》（Journal of Personality and Social Psychology）上，作者们是这样表达的：当我们接受而不是评判我们的心理体验时，我们会让这些体验遵循其自然且相对短命的进程，而不是去聚焦并加剧它们。所以这就是我的最后一条建议。
Express your sadness. Find ways to communicate it to your friends. Find a home for it. Find an expression for it. Find a way to sit with it even when it's uncomfortable. And the research tells us that counterintuitively, it actually makes it. us happier in the long term. Here are some quick final notes for me on this. You don't have to do all of these things. You know, that's a lot of work. Just choose one or two of these tips and implement them
表达你的悲伤。寻找与朋友沟通的方式。为它找一个安身之所。为它找一个表达的出口。寻找一种即使在不舒服时也能与之共存的方式。研究告诉我们，与直觉相反的是，从长远来看，这实际上会让我们更快乐。以下是我对此的一些简短的最后结语。你不必把所有这些事情都做了。你知道，那工作量太大了。只需选择其中一两个建议，然后慢慢去践行。
slowly. Implement them over time and just notice whether something changes. You know, I'm not going to choose which one you should do first because I think that all five are really important, but whichever one resonates with you most, that is the one that you should choose. And I always, I always, also want to say one more time, don't forget the other core components of your well-being. I know I said I wouldn't talk about exercise or eating well or going to therapy, but, you know, those are our foundations. You can't really accept your sadness or have a project or think that going outdoors is going to do as much as getting those basics down pat will do in the first place. So really, I'm rooting for you. These, you know, with small changes comes big.
随着时间推移去践行它们，然后注意看看是否有什么改变。你知道，我不会替你选择你应该先做哪一个，因为我觉得这五个建议都很重要，但无论是哪一个最能引起你的共鸣，那就是你应该选择的。而且我总是，我总是想再次强调，不要忘记你福祉的其他核心组成部分。我知道我说过我不会谈论锻炼、健康饮食或去看心理医生，但是，你知道，那是我们的基础。你不可能真正地接受你的悲伤，或者拥有一个项目，或者认为去户外能起到多大作用，除非你首先把这些基础工作做好。所以真的，我在为你加油。这些，你知道的，小小的改变会带来大大的
big impact and big results. And I just want you to remember the happiness pie. When life feels overwhelming, you get to control 40% of it. That is all up to you and your perception. So I'm sending a lot of love and strength. If you enjoyed this episode, please feel free to share it with somebody else who you think might also benefit from it, who you think might get something from this.
影响和巨大的成果。我只是希望你记住“幸福饼图”。当生活让人感到不堪重负时，你可以掌控其中的40%。这完全取决于你和你的认知。所以我在此送出许多爱与力量。如果你喜欢这一集，请随时把它分享给其他人，你认为他们也可能会从中受益，你认为他们可能会从中学到些什么。
and if you do feel cool to do so, please leave a review five stars. Of course, it would really make my day. It helps the show grow. It helps this information get to more people. And it just makes me really happy. Make sure you're following along as well so you know when new episodes are coming out. If you have feedback, an episode suggestion, something to say, something to contribute, something that you even disagree with, whatever it is.
如果你确实觉得有必要这样做，请留下五星好评。当然，这真的会让我的这一天都变得美好。它有助于节目的成长，有助于将这些信息传递给更多的人。这真的让我非常开心。同时也请确保关注我们，这样你就知道什么时候会有新节目推出。如果你有反馈、节目建议、想说的话、想贡献的内容、甚至是你不同意的观点，无论是什么。
Please feel free to follow me and DM me at That Psychology. podcast with all your questions, queries, concerns, inquiries, topics, suggestions, whatever it is. I would love to hear from you. And as always, we will be back on Friday with another episode. 2%. That's the number of people who take the stairs when there is also an escalator available. I'm Michael Easter. I'm on my podcast, 2%. I break down the science of mental toughness, fitness, and building resilience in our strange modern world. Put yourself through some hardships, and you will come out on the other side a happier, more fulfilled, healthier person. Listen to 2%.
请随时关注我并通过私信联系我：That Psychology podcast，发送你的所有问题、疑问、担忧、咨询、主题建议，无论是什么。我很乐意听到你的声音。和往常一样，我们将在周五带着另一集节目回归。《2%》。这就是在旁边也有自动扶梯的情况下选择走楼梯的人数比例。我是迈克尔·伊斯特。在我的播客《2%》中，我将剖析精神坚韧度、体能以及在我们这个奇特的现代世界中建立复原力的科学。让自己经历一些艰难困苦，然后你就会以一个更快乐、更有成就感、更健康的自己从另一端走出来。收听《2%》。
That's T.O.0%. On the Iheart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. On the Look Back at it podcast. From 1979, that was a big moment for me. 84's big to me. I'm Sam J. And I'm Alex English. Each episode, we pick a here, unpack what went down, and try to make sense of how we survived it.
也就是在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方搜索“T.O.0%”。在《回顾过去》播客中。从1979年开始，那对我是个重大的时刻。84年对我很重要。我是萨姆·J。我是亚历克斯·英格利什。每一集，我们都会挑选一个年份，剖析当时发生的事情，并试着理解我们是如何挺过来的。
with our friends, fellow comedians, and favorite authors. Like Mark Lamont Hill on the 80s. It was a wild year. It was a wild year. I don't think there's a more important year for black people. Listen to look back at it on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. Hey, what's good, y'all? You're listening to Learn the Hard Way with your favorite therapist and host Kier Games.
和我们的朋友、同为喜剧演员的同行以及最喜欢的作家一起。比如请来马克·拉蒙特·希尔畅谈80年代。那是个疯狂的年份。那是个疯狂的年份。我不认为对黑人来说还有比这更重要的年份了。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Look Back at It》。嘿，最近怎么样，各位？你们正在收听《Learn the Hard Way》，我是你们最喜欢的治疗师兼主持人基尔·盖恩斯。
This space is about black men's experiences, having honest conversations that's really not safe to have anywhere, but you're not. you're having him with a licensed professional who knows what he's doing. How many men carry a suit or armor. It signals to the world that you're not to be played with. And just because you have the capability that does not mean that you need to, listen to learn the hard way on the AHA radio app, Apple Podcast, or wherever you get your podcast. In 2023, Bachelor star Clayton Eckerd was accused of fathering twins.
这个空间是关于黑人男性的经历的，进行一些在任何地方都真的不太安全的坦诚对话，但在这里你是安全的。你是在和一个知道自己在做什么的持证专业人士进行对话。有多少男人穿着一套盔甲。它向世界发出信号，表明你是不好惹的。仅仅因为你有这种能力，并不意味着你就必须这么做，在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Learn the Hard Way》。在2023年，《单身汉》明星克莱顿·埃克德被指控怀有双胞胎。
But the pregnancy appeared to be a hoax. You doctored this particular test twice, Ms. Owens, correct? I doctored the test ones. It took an army of internet detectives to uncover a disturbing pattern. Two more men who'd been through the same thing. Greg Gillespie and Michael Rancini. My mind was blown. I'm Stephanie Young.
但这次怀孕似乎是个骗局。你曾两次篡改这个特定的测试，欧文斯女士，对吗？我篡改过一次测试。这需要一群互联网侦探来揭露一个令人不安的模式。另外两个经历过相同事情的男士。格雷格·吉莱斯皮（Greg Gillespie）和迈克尔·兰西尼（Michael Rancini）。我的天哪，太震惊了。我是斯蒂芬妮·杨。
This is Love Trapped. Laura, Scottsdale Police. As the season continues, Laura Owens finally faces consequences. Listen to Love Trapped podcast on the IHeart Radio app, Apple Podcasts, or wherever you get your podcasts. This is an IHeart podcast. Guaranteed human. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是《Love Trapped》。劳拉，斯科茨代尔警方。随着节季的继续，劳拉·欧文斯终于面临了后果。在iHeartRadio App、苹果播客或任何你收听播客的地方收听《Love Trapped》播客。这是一档iHeart播客。真人保证。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。